hey what's up guys it's Rob and welcome
to my tutorial for the rune drill du
Marais in my last video I released on my
birthday I did a vlog where I showed a
new design of yet another boomerang that
I came up with I know I know
I like boomerangs what can I say and
here's how it flies thank you all so
much for the birthday wishes and
comments on the last video I actually
got a jetski for my birthday that you
can see on my Instagram and I've been
out a lot which is why I got this pan
the boomerangs actually based off the
windmill or pinwheel just like the ninja
Tristar boomerang was and today I'm
gonna show you how to make it it's
actually one of the simpler designs I've
done for the boomerang and it just
requires one sheet of printer paper like
this I don't recommend you try origami
paper because it's a little bit too thin
and does apply as well
I know boomerangs gonna be somewhat
challenging to get working so I'm gonna
do my best to go into detail and explain
how to throw it at the end so be sure to
pay close attention it flies really well
but I would recommend making more than
one that way you could test out
different models because some will fly
better than others and also practice how
to throw it and you'll be a pro in no
time if you do enjoy the video be sure
to give it a thumbs up down below and
also click that subscribe a notification
bell to stay notified so once you have
the paper let's get to it I'm gonna
first make the paper into a square by
taking the upper right corner and the
top edge and aligning it with the left
side just like this once the edges are
lined up then I can make a crease along
the right side here make a nice sharp
crease by running your fingernail over
it and I'm just gonna tear off or cut
off this excess paper I prefer to tear
it so I just flip it over like this take
the edge and fold it down right along
this bottom edge right here then you can
just unfold this
give it a really sharp crease like that
and then you could hold it like this and
just tear it so now we have a crease
going diagonally like this I'm just
going to take the upper left corner and
fold it down to the bottom right corner
now line up the edges and make another
crease so now if you open up the paper
you'll see that you have an X in it so
I'm just going to make a mark so you
could see it a little easier and now I'm
going to make a mark that's about 3/8 of
an inch or about a centimeter away from
the center you can also try using the
width of your pinky if you don't have a
ruler or don't want to use one take the
edge and fold it down to that mark and
just make a crease across the top and
just make it nice and sharp
then you could unfold it and now we're
going to turn it like that and we're
going to fold this edge down right at
the place where these two intersect so
as you'll see they intersect right here
so I'm going to be folding it along that
intersection just like this so just fold
it down until you see the point where
they intersect and just make sure that
these edges line up like this and these
two points give it a pinch right there
and then you can crease it all the way
across the top then you can unfold it
and just do the same with the other two
sides then you can unfold it and we're
just going to pinch all of the corners
like this and we're going to press these
two edges here all the way down to the
center so once they're all the way down
to the center then we could fold this
whole edge straight down like that so as
you'll see we made this new fold right
here then you could turn it like this
and we're just going to do the same here
pinch the bottom right corner and bring
the bottom and right edges straight
and bring the corner down and continue
to do that for the rest of them then you
could press everything into the middle
like this and you'll see we've created
the windmill base except it has a square
in the middle here they should each be
the same distance away from the middle
once you have something like this just
make sure it's nice and flat and then we
can flip it over now you'll see we have
a center point here I'm just going to
mark and we're going to take each of the
edges here and fold it down to the
center point so let's take this one here
I'm just going to round it off a little
bit like this and fold this edge down to
that Center mark when I fold it down to
the center mark you'll see this other
corner will come up all right but we're
not going to fold it on the outside here
we're going to be pressing on the inside
of this little pocket area so just take
the edge pull it down to the middle it's
easier to do this on a table once the
edge is lined up like that then just
make a crease right here just press it
like that and just crease to the left
side then we could just push our finger
in this little pocket area here like
that just give it a press it will go
right up to this corner here you don't
want to crease on the outside here so
once we crease like that then we can
unfold it turn it and we're going to do
the same with this edge fold it directly
down to the center point press it down
in the middle like that press right here
and crease all the way to the left
give it a nice sharp crease and just
press right in this little pocket area
unfold it turn it do the same with these
two just like the other two fold the
edge straight down to the middle crease
to the left and press in the pocket
finally with the last one
same thing edge straight down crease it
all the way across and press in the
pocket so now if you unfold everything
you'll have something that looks just
like this we're going to do the same
thing that we did on the other side
where we closed them all to create the
windmill except we're going to be doing
it in a counterclockwise direction now
so I'm just going to pinch this little
corner here and I'm going to press
here like this now this bottom edge is
going to be pressed into the middle and
then these edges are going to be folded
down like this so it's bottom edge and
then left edge and when you press the
bottom edge it'll crease along this
diagonal fold so just press the bottom
and then press the left just like that
and as you'll see they'll crease
directly in the middle like that then
you can just press it down and we've
made this new fold right here do the
same with the other three so it should
look like this then we're just going to
press all the edges into the middle like
this and as you'll see they'll be
closing in this direction so just press
everything into the middle like that and
they should all come together in the
center so just flatten it out and it
should look like this now and you'll see
on each of the four arms of the
boomerang we have this little tab or
overlap which basically serves as an
airfoil to help the boomerang spin in
that circle what I do is I lift up this
arm here and I pull the tab here down as
far as I can and to do that I basically
crease it here like this round it off a
little bit and pull it down as far as I
can so as you'll see I pulled it down
and it creased a little bit on the back
as well and just do that with the rest
of them all three
and now what I'm going to do is just
flip it over and once again flatten it
out now with those flaps fold it over
once I flattened it out really well I'm
just going to go over these little flaps
here with my fingernail really sharp and
now we're ready to throw it to throw the
boomerang we're to make sure that we're
holding all four of these flaps facing
the left side also make sure that these
tips are not bent downwards towards the
flaps like this you can actually take
your finger and just round them up
holding the flaps facing down and just
round them up like that slightly and
that'll actually help it stabilize and
hover a little bit so make sure that
these little flaps are not tucked under
the arm here like that but they're
actually over it otherwise it will not
be aerodynamic and will not fly well
then we're gonna take it with the flaps
facing to the left
hold your pointer and middle finger like
this and put it in between them like
that holding it right around the end of
the flap then you're gonna take your
hand curl your wrist and you're gonna
flick it out like that up at like a
twenty or thirty degree angle giving it
a really nice spin don't hold it flat
like this and throw it out because it'll
actually flip upside down and won't come
back properly so you're going to try to
throw it vertically and flick your wrist
out
I hope you guys enjoyed the video if you
did don't forget to smash that like
button down below and also hit that
subscribe a notification bell to stay
notified thanks to everyone for watching
my other two boomerang videos I'm glad
you guys seem to like it and enjoy it as
much as I did and thanks to all my new
subscribers I didn't think I now have
over five hundred and eighty three
thousand so welcome to my channel be
sure to practice your throw and also let
me know you throw the video down below
and I'd love to hear what you like to
see next I hope you're all enjoying the
summer and I'll see you soon